today's question comes from amy nebraska
she writes in i have a job interview
coming up for an entry-level position as
an assistant manager
for a coffee chain if salary is not
brought up by my
interviewer when is the best time for me
to ask about it
uh you ask about it when they offer you
the job because presumably
not always but presumably when they
offer you the job amy they're going to
tell you what they are offering the job
at as an
hourly rate and at that point then you
can discuss that but i would not ask
about it early on i always tell people
dave in the interview process
uh you want to convince that hiring
manager that you will help them win
we've got to remember that
they're people too and they're looking
for somebody that's going to help them
win and so uh there will come a time in
this particular question
where uh the uh the hourly rate the
salary whatever that is is going to come
up
completely through the interview and
you're walking out of your first
interview and you still have
no idea what the pay is you don't ask
well
fair question but in this situation um
you can
you have a good idea what an hourly rate
is going to be at a coffee shop you have
a pretty good idea and you can find that
out
pretty easily you have a ballpark range
i mean it's not going to be
something like seven eight nine dollars
an hour you're probably going to be in
that
low range would be 10 with the minimum
wage politicizing that's going on right
now you're probably going to be in that
12 to 15
an hour so you shouldn't walk into an
interview like that going
i have no idea what i can and can't do
so it's a good point to bring up but you
have to have an eye an eye on the type
of work
and do your homework prior to the job
that's what i teach you can find out
what people are paying you can find out
if it's a good coffee shop to work at
before you ever show up
so i agree with the general sentiment
that you would not
uh if someone i teach our guys here in
recruiting
if they lead with what do you pay what
are the benefits
just end the interview yeah totally
agree because they're here for what they
can take not what they can give
yeah and so it's over yeah and so that's
the other end of that sentiment right
uh uh but i i would be perfectly
careful at the end of the interview if
nothing has been brought up
to start with that's a really sucky
interviewer
that does not cover some of what's going
on that is true
that is true but uh if that's the case
uh you get to the end of it and just go
hey i really appreciate our time our
conversation
i think i can add value here if this
were to work out what is the
general yeah i'm playing with that i'm
fine with that what's the range i'm fine
with it or something like that yes just
so i kind of
so i kind of know what to anticipate and
then you can go
because that you may want to rule them
out yes
you may not want to go through three
interviews and get hired for
half of what you think you're gonna get
well you're not going to go through
three interviews
for an hourly wage like this for an
actual job so i
that is good context that i agree with
my point is this
when you're going for an entry level
position you need to have already done
your homework on that place
do they treat people like they're just
robots and soulless people and they're
just moving burn and churn through this
do some homework find out is this a
great place to work you can do that very
easily it's not difficult with all the
resources we have in this world
so with that being the context i'm
always wanting people to show up at that
interview
and and absolutely blow them away so
that they go they
want you and the time comes that's good
practice for a real job it is because
you're not going to bring up salary
you're not going to bring that up in the
first now you better not i mean it's bad
i mean i had a young guy i'll never
forget one of the way
back i mean we had 10 people and we had
this young guy i ran into him i was
speaking at church he came up he was
real enthusiastic afterwards i was
talking to him for 20 minutes
and i said you know he said are you
you're hiring for anything i said yeah
yeah and he came over and he sat down
it was so disappointing because he was
such a rock star in
so many ways but the first thing out of
his mouth is okay what's this pay
yeah and what are your benefits
packaging it makes me cringe hearing
it's because because he you know he
instantly revealed his heart
yes which is i'm here to take rather
than to add
yes and i can't come into the business i
own with that attitude yeah i'm here
what can i take versus what can i add
you better put some water in the bucket
or there'll be no water in the bucket
and remember for entry level jobs you're
up against a lot of people
it's a factory so i want you to put your
best foot forward i'm not
i like what you said i'd be okay with
that but i want you to win the position
when they're trusting confidence when
they offer it then you say
you're probably going to do that in that
first interview yeah
because to your point to your point
they're not gonna do six interviews like
we did and they're shuffling people
through
yeah and uh so you want to be classy you
know did you fog up the mirror okay yeah
well in some places that's the case yeah
if yeah
you can get hired smiles pass the drug
test and fog up a mirror
yes you don't even have to smile i can
prove that by some of the people that
serve coffee so i'm just telling you
bad experience dave i won't bring up a
brand